on a retrouvé des archives incroyable
d'emmanuel macron lorsqu'il était jeune
alors est encore jeune un des artistes
ont été diffusés dans le documentaire de
france 3 macron la stratégie du météore
y la saison il joue une pièce de théâtre
et il impressionnait brigitte regarder
[Musique]
en rejoignant cet atelier de théâtre le
jeune emmanuel a fait une rencontre qui
a bouleversé son existence
[Applaudissements]
il est tombé amoureux de surpresseurs
brigitte aux hier de 24 ans son aîné
il avait joué effectivement et jouer un
épouvantail ils jouent à je me souviens
très très bien et je trouvais qu'il
était incroyable sur scène puisqu'elle
présence voilà alors c'est vrai que ça
c'est une archive incroyable il paraît
qu'il est très jaloux emmanuel macron
oui il est avec moi y était aussi avec
celle où la grogne a pris c'est que ses
collaborateurs débutants politique ouais
il a peur qu'on lui refasse le coup
qu'il a fait à hollande à certaines
heures il a peur qu'ils aient une tête
qui dépasse donc il fait attention que
il n'ya pas de gens qui aiment trop
difficile redouter une percée politique
de benjamin griveaux on a vu benjamin
gallezot avait percé mais pas en
politique pour percer il a percé il est
tranquille maintenant et redoute
toujours l'émergence d'un nouveau macron
vous savez la peur qui se repassent ce
qui s'est passé en benjamin griveaux
riche de percer chez jackie et michel
mais en vérité il peut être également
très dur avec ses collaborateurs rica il
est très exigeant avec eux considèrent
qu'à partir du moment où on travaille à
l'elysée on est un militant
sacrificielle on doit se donner corps et
âme si on n'est pas content on s'en va
ils firent pas les gens mais il veut
qu'ils s'en aillent d'eux-mêmes et dit
en public tu m'appelles monsieur prix
qui m'appellent monsieur le président et
disent à un collaborateur au tout début
parce qu'ils sont un cocktail à les
numéros de rang privé vous avez là
monsieur le président c'est un nom mais
comme il est toujours dit qu'il est
sympathique mine de rien beaucoup de
gens l'agent polluant moins de disques
il est bon vous avez été séduite non non
c'est non jamais il a jamais s'il ne
séduirait jamais jamais mais non c'est
bien voilà intéressé par le personnage
mais oui je suis toujours resté à
distance c'est mieux quand on écrit un
livre et il est il est affable il peut
avoir une espèce de sympathie parfois un
peu mécanique mais c'est pas quelqu'un
de sympathique parce que c'est quelqu'un
qui est très exigeant avec les gens et
qu'il essaie plutôt de convaincre
souvent plutôt que de plus plutôt que
d'être dans dans la secte dans
l'empathie pour autant vous n'allez
pourtant vous le décrivez comme
quelqu'un d'éminemment séducteur
dragueur ses droïdes rails
oui drague un concurrent et drague
quelqu'un qui compte y va d'autres sur
les marchés et drague tout le temps fut
il veut séduire les politiques comme la
wii
et pour autant sympathique il fascine
les gens parce que il est à arbonne par
le regard il a un regard bleu
transparent dont les fixes comme ça dans
les yeux comment les touches une fille
et sa garde
il est très tactile mais il cherche pas
à déclencher tellement de sympathie
c'est les gens qui viennent vers lui
parce qu'ils se sentent valorisés par ce
type très brillant très intelligent qui
s'intéressent à eux et qui les écoutent
les emplois une capacité t'écoute
absolument formidable de concentration
quand il est avec quelqu'un et regarde
jamais son portable et donc les gens
sont très flatté alors est ce qui prend
les décisions vraiment tout seul où est
ce qu'ils écoutent beaucoup la vie des
autres mais deux les deux états des îles
a biffé de synthèse
il décide tout seul et a besoin de
beaucoup écouté au point que parfois il
prend du retard dans les décisions
tellement ils écoutent y consultent et
il tranche sol et c'est lui qui dessert
c'est donc vos jeux va présenter serena
tu vas te présenter comme il tranche
seul croyez-moi je tranche avec vous
trancher dans le lard oui d'un film we
corinne j'ai une petite question en fait
vous évoquez vraiment des passages très
intime en fait de l'avis du de la
famille et du couple mais on sait qu
emmanuel macron fait quand même très
attention à sa communication et c'est
quelqu'un qui a beaucoup d'ego alors
comment est ce que vous avez fait pour
vraiment avoir le sincère en fait dans
tout ça j'ai beaucoup parlé
je le suis depuis depuis onze ans pas
tous les jours mais j'ai beaucoup parlé
j'ai vu 120 personnes au total dont
évidemment lui-même et brigitte macro je
connais très bien les gens qui
l'entourent qui l'ont suivi dans son
parcours
je les ai vus souvent à plusieurs
reprises en un an et afin de mettre les
gens en confiance de les connaître et de
les faire parler
on arrive à approcher de la réalité de
quelqu'un alors vous raconter qu
emmanuel macron la télé allumée toute la
journée
il est connecté en permanence vous dit
même qu'il est hypnotisé par bfm tv vous
raconter une scène étonnante qu'a lieu
lors d'un remaniement ministériel le
président est devant bfm tv et il
s'exclame regardez moi ces connards
c'est le plan classique des remaniements
ministériels les chaînes d'info en
continu elles sont en train de commenter
intel va rentrer au gouvernement sur
partir etc
c'est leur boulot à et lui ça les nerfs
parce qu'il est en train de composer
bout en bout
et c'est pas tu vas rentrer parce que
ces trucs là ça se décide toujours à la
dernière jury il ya toujours des
surprises ça énerve et en même temps il
est fasciné
comme par le serpent kaa et regarde bfm
et bfm tv talmud toute la journée dans
l'arrière garde seignosse parquet à
l'aller regarde c'est nous à se lasser
canton la paix on le dit c'est pas le
même temps pour bernard me connais bien
emmanuel macron et brigitte mâcon dont
les parce que vous vous reconnaissez le
président et brigitte oui alors je
trouve sincèrement que c'est bien fait
une première question quand même temps
avez vous concrètement passé avec madame
macro et monsieur macron alors une heure
et demie avec que c'est tout faux
poursuit pour le livre avec monsieur
groupe les a suivis pendant nos rives
oui mais c'est monsieur grandjean qui
vous a présentement crouch les vieux
aussi plusieurs canons mais c'est une
question sans ça fait six ans parce que
c'est quand on écrit un livre sur
quelqu'un si on a rencontré que pendant
une heure et demie oui je sais bien mais
moi j'ai fait j'ai fait plusieurs fois
des intervenants accroc mais c'est
plusieurs déplacés réfugiés pendant
l'itinérance mémorial dans le nord et
l'est de la france fin 2010 8 j'ai
décidé d'un déplacement européen
j'ai fait plusieurs déjeuner avec lui
plusieurs rencontres pour le livre
spécifiquement qui a duré quelques mois
de travail
ah oui en contre et je les rencontre et
1h30 et oui mais bon ma kourina mais
j'avais déjà rencontré brigitte m'a dit
que nous avions pendant la campagne
est ce qu'ils les trouvaient pas ce
qu'on va pas revenir sur sa vie ici est
ce que vous retrouvez les non initiés
c'est très juste c'est il ya plein de
choses très très bien il ya qu un truc
qui m'a extrêmement choquée parce que je
ne voyais pas cet artiste là parler
comme ça au président ou en tout cas au
ministre à l'époque quand vous dites
voulez vous l'écrivez dans le livre que
jamel debbouze aurait dit ferme ta
gueule alors on va y donne ça sera un
dîner qui se serait passé
organisé par luc besson en 2016 emmanuel
macron est alors candidat à l'élection
présidentielle de 2017
ils se retrouvent à table avec nicolas
hulot et jamel macron parler des
banlieues avec un discours apparemment
assez formaté et la formidable énergie
de ces jeunes d'habitants et la jam elle
s'est lâchée la sortie écoute monsieur
ministre tu vas fermer ta gueule et
jamel debbouze nous a appelés et nous a
dit que c'était faux à l'inversé n'est
pas vrai ça m'a été rapportée par un
participant qui était au déjeuner et à
l'or et aux lyonnais pardon et qui a
assisté à la scène alors djamel dit que
c'est faux le foie lui alors il est me
dit voilà donc être géré et demi
c'était faux soit jamel un problème de
mémoire soit nos interlocuteurs il a
fallu non alors je vais vous dire
pardonnez moi madame je vous respecte
mais évidemment il n'ya pas le problème
simplement c'est que j'ai appelé
effectivement djamel hier soir à 23
heures il était très en colère même
appelé également aussi je vous dis était
très en colère elle m'appelait ils
étaient treize ans la bonne came elle
voulait que j'appelle la baie appelé le
oui vous voulez que ya pas de carmen est
en colère même pas ce qu'il n'a jamais
dit ça parce qu'il est toujours très
respectueux diamètre s'est dit sur le
ton de l'humour dans sa prière peu de la
première jean-paul jamel il était très
en colère et et d'après un conseiller de
l'elysée j'ai appelé aussi l'elysée on
m'a dit que c'est impossible d'autant
plus que le président l'apprécient
énormément et un très bon rapport
mais alors excusez-moi la remarque et ai
dit sur le ton de la boutade un peu
provocatrice oui comme je pense que çà
çà çà ça correspond assez au tempérament
déjà versé diabète oui moi duhamel mon
frérot et c'est jamel qui me rappelle
voilà et donc voilà dont mais jamel
c'est vrai il dit que c'était il
disparaît mais bon je joue c'est s'était
pas contredit au balcon c'est peut-être
non absolument au contraire c'était pour
dire que macron avait été à la fois
interloqué et un peu déstabilisé par
cette remarque parce qu'il n'a pas
l'habitude d'entendre ministre de
l'économie de s'entendre parler comme ça
sur et de booster sa manière de parler
alors dans votre livre on sent ce
registre on apprend que bernard tapie
chez jamel va peut-être me rappelais
fait une prédiction assez macabre
président a raconté une conversation
oui c'est quoi mon problème lui demande
macron président vous allez vous faire
buter à la kennedy
il y a dans ce pays dix mille mecs qui
se suicident chaque année il y en a bien
un qui le fera en mouture qui le fera en
voiture oh oui macron à renouer afin a
noué avec tapie alors qu'ils voulaient
pas le voir pendant longtemps et tapie
va le voir à l'elysée et maquereau le
dis c'est quoi mon problème et tapie qui
a une manière de parler assez cash
il a peur et il a raison d'avoir peur
parce que les flics disent la même chose
que macro soient assassinés parce que
macro ont déclenché beaucoup de haine
au point que certaines personnes si on
va avoir envie de le but est comme son
tapis au sens propre du terme
et tapie a alerté macron là dessus mais
macron le sais parce que les flics ont
exactement les mêmes informations c'est
à dire qu'il ya un risque d'attentât
contre ce président est il inquiet de ça
il paraît que c'est surtout bruyant il a
très peur de ça ils man
faye stock femme alors peut-être que ça
peut-être qu'il l'aimait ils manifestent
beaucoup de distance par rapport à ça
ils pensent que c'est pas lui
personnellement qui est taclé mais que
c'est la fonction présidentielle mais
dégage beaucoup d'émotion si c'est vrai
père bah merci je suis vous avez tout à
l'heure il déclenche de l'émotion il
déclenche beaucoup de passion qu'à soi
d'ailleurs posé pied il a une fois on
voit moi j'ai connu depuis début 2007
bien avant qu'il soit candidat ou un
genou qui dégage une certaine empathie
mais surtout il est fascinant je trouve
qu'il est assez fascinant pour qu'ils
parlent d'abord quand on vous parlait
comme vous l'avez dit très bien
tout à l'heure il vous écoute énormément
il est complètement avec vous et je
trouve que ça dégage une certaine
sympathie surtout quand on connaît le
temps que vous donnent certains
politiques a offert son monde vous
écoutez lui il vous écoute réellement et
une écoute active ça ils aiment le temps
long on le voit les hommes dans ses
prises de parole il aime prendre le
temps avec les gens voilà moi ce qui m'a
vraiment surpris au tout début 2007 je
me suis dit vraiment il a face à nous et
qu'il avait quelque chose à dire qu'il
avait une vision et qu'il n'allait pas
comme ça par hasard il avait un
déterminisme et ça s'est vu pendant
toute la campagne et d'occident sont
alors dans son action présidentielle on
a eu nos archives cb brigitte qui était
donc professeur emmanuel macron élèves
elle se rappelle du comportement qui
avait le jeune emmanuel à l'époque selon
elle il n'était pas comme les autres
[Musique]
ce n'était pas comme les autres
résolument il n'était pas comme les
autres et il était toujours avec les
profs de toute manière il discutait
toujours avec les profs
c'était c'était il y avait toujours des
livres n'est toujours plein de livres il
était toujours c'était pas un ado il
avait un rapport à l'adulte à tous les
adultes aux autres profs au directeur
d'égal à égal
il n'y a jamais eu cette échelle il n'a
jamais respecté
enfin moi je ne les ai jamais vus
respecter cette échelle d'âge alors oui
il a lu votre livre vous avez un retour
à la loge quand il a lu mon lit on pense
que je lui ai fait porter à l'elysée je
n'ai pas de retour à ce stade
d'accord elle alors y apporter brigitte
c'est vraiment c'est c'est quoi c'est
quoi son rouleau à lui elle est
absolument essentiel alors pas en
politique stricto sensu mais elle
intervient beaucoup je pense que sur des
conseils de comportement de mes deux
méthodes
elle lui sert beaucoup un peu
d'ambassadeur auprès de toutes les
personnes que lui n'a pas le temps de
voir donc c'est elle qui va elle joue un
rôle évidemment affectif absolument
exceptionnelle ils passent leur temps
ensemble c'est à dire que quand il est à
l'elysée eva dans son bureau elle va
dans le sien il veut pas comme je
racontais tout à l'heure il veut pas se
séparer d'elle donc c'est vraiment un
couple fusionnel et moi ce que je trouve
assez exceptionnel dans leur couple
s'est pas tellement la différence d'âge
dans ce sens là c'est que c'est un
couple très solide 25 ans d'âge et cette
solidité mais c'est rare c'est contre le
castaldi